turbide à monsieur elie à bout merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
et je voudrais associer à ma question
mon collègue dino cinieri monsieur le
garde des sceaux les phrases prononcées
par un détenu ne se passe pas dans une
fiction romans ou dans le dernier film
d'action sorti dans nos salles de cinéma
non c'était malheureusement dans la
vraie vie
j'ai envie de dire dans la triste vie de
nos prisons mes chers collègues le 21
février dernier un détenu du centre
pénitentiaire de béziers dans l'hérault
s'est filmée depuis sa cellule à l'aide
de son propre téléphone portable et à
partager les images sur les réseaux
sociaux
devant des centaines de milliers de
jeunes
ils disaient vous savez dans la prison
tout est facile tout est possible tout
ce que vous avez envie de l'alcool de la
drogue toutes sortes de drogues et
l'apothéose dit-il avec un sourire
radieux et une assurance affichée digne
d'un héros des temps modernes
vous savez les prisons c'est le club med
mais monsieur le ministre dans quelle
république vivons nous lorsque les
personnels pénitentiaires
mais il a dit mon cher collègue il l'a
dit mon cher collègue il a dit c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est lui qui l'a dit ce
sont les français monsieur le ministre
tous les français tous les personnels
pénitentiaires qui finalement sont
victimes sont mis en danger par la faute
d'une politique laxiste en la matière il
est vrai il est vrai que vous méritez
pas d'un dossier facile tant votre
prédécesseur de son inaction faisait des
gorges chaudes au nom d'un humanisme mal
placé et parfois malheureusement
destructeur ma question est simple mais
si la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
urvoas garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice sous le seul président monsieur
le député elie aboud
je vais vous répondre avec tranquillité
franchise et détermination
ce que vous venez de dire est
inacceptable parce que vous avez dit la
vérité il faut une réponse il faut une
réponse qui soit implacable sur le cas
d'espèce ce détenu a subi deux
procédures une procédure disciplinaire
qui a été engagée immédiatement par le
directeur de l'établissement et une
procédure judiciaire
il est passé en comparution immédiate et
il a été condamné à six mois ferme de
plus que sa peine qu'il purge déjà et
qui était de 4 ans j'imagine que votre
question portait sur le fond c'est à
dire que faut-il faire notamment pour
que ces moyens ne soient plus
accessibles
il y a trois manières d'agir sur les
téléphones portables
d'abord je vous dois la vérité il y a de
plus en plus de téléphones portables qui
sont saisis par les surveillants
pénitentiaires de plus en plus l'année
dernière il y en a eu 25000 pour
résoudre ce problème il ya trois
solutions la première c'est de brouiller
les portables nous avons nous avons ce
moment 628 500 638 pardon 638
brouilleurs en prison qu'ils sont
dépassés parce que la génération
technologique dont ils sont le fait ne
fonctionne pas
trois millions d'euros ont été budgétés
d'ici 2017 pour avoir une nouvelle
génération
je vais aller voir d'ailleurs les
éléments de démonstration puisqu'ils
sont déjà parce qu'il faut des
brouilleurs qu'ils soient très précis on
ne va pas brouiller tout le voisinage de
l'établissement pénitentiaire ou de la
maison d'arrêt on ne va pas brouiller
les communications des surveillants il
faut brouiller les communications
deuxième hypothèse on peut autoriser les
portables des propositions ont été
faites ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement
troisième hypothèse de l'expérimentation
si vous avez une idée je suis preneur
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
la parole est à m